翻訳: Mari Arimitsu
校正: Saeko Hashimoto
皆さん こんにちは
本当は英語で
喋らなきゃいけないんですけれど
あまり上手ではないので
今日は日本語で喋らせてください
今 パトリックが紹介してくれて
少しハードルの高いスピーチになっていますが
最近 渋谷区では―
同性パートナーシップに関する
ニュースが沢山 出ています
この間の３月の議会でですね
パートナーシップ証明書の発行について
議論がされて それに結論が出て
条例が可決しました
（拍手）
おーすごい
これについては 色々
騒がれていたんですけれど
急だ、とか
何で急にこんなことが起きたんだ―
日本で、東京で、渋谷でと
言われていると思うんですけど
僕にとっては３年以上かかる
長いストーリーなんです
何でこんなことを思いついたかというと
提案した時は３年前 当時は渋谷の
区議会議員をしていました
区議会議員は合計３期の
12年していたんですけれども
その中で色んな政策を提案して
渋谷区で実現してきたわけですけども
何でこのパートナーシップに至ったか
今思うと出会いは―
LGBTのことを自分自身で
感じるようになったのは
20歳くらいの時に
初めてアメリカに旅行しに行った時です
今 僕は43歳ですから
約20年前 その頃のニューヨークは
まだ地下鉄も落書きが多かったり
世界ではちょうどAIDS/HIVについて
いろいろ語られている時でした
ですから 初めて行ったアメリカは怖くて
友達と二人だったんですけれど
ちょっと怖くてですね
電車に乗ったら 地下鉄は落書きだらけで
座っていると
僕より背の高い 身体の大きい
アメリカ人が沢山いて
「この中にエイズの人が
何人いるんだろう」とか
知識がないから そうやって
すごくドキドキしていました
その後 メトロポリタン美術館に行ったり
ワシントンD.C.に行って
スミソニアン博物館なんかを回るんですけど
なぜだか分からないんですけど
そのミュージアムの警備員の男性に
やたらナンパされるんですね（笑）
不思議な経験でした
ニューヨークで１回
ワシントンD.C. で３回
「この後ランチどうだい」とか
「ワシントンには
良いクラブがあるんだよ」って
何だかわからなかった
でも すごくビックリして
気持ち悪いっていう気は
そんなになかったけど
とにかく驚いたんですね
その後サンフランシスコに行ったらですね
これまたもっとビックリで
モヒカン頭の青年とちょっと禿げたおじさんが
手をつないで信号を渡っていたりしてですね
東京とは違うな 日本とは違うなと言うのを
すごく感じて帰ってきました
でも僕が生まれ育ったのは
原宿っていう街です
東京に帰ってきて よく周りを見渡したら
「美容師さんにそういう人がいるなあ」
とかですね
「洋服屋さんにそういう人がいるなあ」
っていうことを
段々と気がつくようになってきたんです
その後は 今度は会社に入って
広告代理店に就職しました
クリエイティブな世界には
割とLGBTの人がいました
わかりやすい人もいれば
わかりにくい人もいたけど
なんかまた 俺ゲイっぽかったのかな
分からないですけど
カミングアウトされる機会が
多かったりとかですね
段々気づいていくと
優秀な人たちが多いなと思ったんです
わかりやすい人、カミングアウトしている人は
とにかく自分に自信があったり
仕事にも上手くいっている人が多いから
ポジティブな気持ちでいられるから
カミングアウトしているのかなと思います
段々 そういう人たちと
触れる機会が増えてですね
優秀だな かっこいいなと
思うようにもなりました
もちろん新宿２丁目に飲みに行ったり
六本木のニューハーフのバーに
遊びに行ったこともあるんですけど
そうやって普通に触れていくうちに
段々自分の中では普通になってきていたんです
そんなことを経験しながら
30歳を過ぎて
政治の世界に
足を踏み入れることになってですね
自分は政治家になりたいというよりは
広告ではプロデューサーとして
仕事をしてきたつもりだから
今度はソーシャルプロデュース
街のプロデュースをしたいんだと
そして自分の生まれ育った街
原宿、そして渋谷、表参道の
プロデューサーになれたら
ちょっとクールかなという思いから
誘われて おだてられて
木に登った気分もあってですね
思い切って選挙に出てみて
そして選挙とほぼシンクロしてですね
ゴミ拾いのNPOを表参道で作りました
『グリーンバード -greenbird-』という
NPOなんですけれど
若い人たちが中心に ゴミ拾いを
楽しくやるっていうNPOです
そこにですね これは出会いだったんですけど
トランスジェンダーの―
今は僕は彼って呼んでますが
当時は女子大生で
今はだんだん 男になっていった
元女性で男になりたい
体は女の子だけれど
心は男という人に会ったんですね
当時はボーイッシュな女性という
印象だったんですけど
ここ十年 今は完璧ないいおじさん
彼は望み通り いいおじさんになりました
おばさんになるんじゃないって言われるのが
すごい嫌だったんですね
でも彼が子供の頃―
彼は女子中学校、女子校
女だけの学校に行ってたんですね
だからセーラー服にルーズソックスで
学校に通っていて
すごく嫌な思いをしていたらしいんです
環境が環境だから 当然その学校に
通っていたわけですけど
親子の関係も結構微妙で
親になかなかカミングアウトできなくて
自分は男になりたいのにどうしてだろう
おかしいな、おかしいな
そんな話を聞いたり
周りと上手く馴染めなかったり
そんな話を聞いていました
彼はその時 そんな本を
出版しようと思っていたので
昔の話 あとこれから実は周りに沢山いて
そういう人たちと
コミュニケーションをとりながら
この課題を解決していきたいんだ
という思いを聞きました
実際 友達になってみると
最初 僕もどう接していいんだろうって
一瞬思ったんですけれど
段々と普通に接していって
今では平気で「このおなべ！」とかって
これは別に差別のつもりじゃなくて
言えるような間柄です
そこで多く感じてきたのは
彼もとても優秀
今まで会ってきた人たちも
とても優秀
でもここで「あれっ」と
気づいたことがあるんです
僕が今まで会ってきた人っていうのは
元男の人ばっかりなんですね
よく考えたら日本でテレビに出ている
LGBTの人も元男性
初めて元女性という人に会って
彼に言われて
「こういう問題を抱えている人は
意外に沢山いるんだよ」と
当時は [人口の] ５パーセントの人が
いると言われていました
今はちょっと上がって
７パーセントになってましたけど
５パーセントというとですね
日本人で言う７百万人くらいの人なんですね
７百万人ってどれくらいの数字だろうと
なかなか頭に浮かばないと思うんですけど
日本人の名字の多い人のベスト４
佐藤さん、鈴木さん、田中さん、高橋さん
この名字の人と同じ数の人がいるんです
そう思うと
えっ、すごいいるな
でもそんなにいない感じするけど
なんでだろう？と思ったんですけど
さっき言ったように
僕が会ってきた人は元男で
しかもカミングアウトしている人と言ったら
またごく少数で
だから言えてない人が元男性でも
沢山後ろにいて、その裏にいて
その出会った彼 文野君って
言うんですけど
彼が元女性・・・
こんがらがってきた
彼とか彼女とか（笑）
元女性だったけど トランスジェンダーの
文野君のようなタイプの―
元女性の子はもっと同じように沢山いる
そう思ったら
この５パーセントっていう数字は
まんざら嘘じゃないなあというように
感じるようになって
それだけ多くの人が
悩んでいるんだったら
何かできないかなと
自然と思うようになりました
同じようにこの５パーセントという
数字で言うと
障がい者も同じような数字なんです
でも障がい者は国から補助も出たり
渋谷区も補助を出したり
色々皆サポートしています
だけど目に見えない
LGBTの人たちには
そんなサポートがないっていうことに
気づいたんです
何ができるかなあと
もちろん同性婚ができるようになったら
すごくいいなあと思ったけど
地方議員の地方議会のレイヤーで
僕らができることは何だろう？と
ふと思ったんですけれど
僕も結婚しています
３人の子供がいるんですけど
結婚もですね
レストランウェディングでやって
ちょっとロマンティックに
皆の前で誓った時が
俺たちの結婚記念日だねなんて
言っていたんですけれど
区役所にですね
入籍届けを出した時も
実はすごく結婚したなって思いました
だから もしかしたら戸籍とかは
いじれないけれども
渋谷区で君たちはパートナーだって
認められるような
そんな証明書が発行できたら
すごくいいんじゃないかと
ポッと浮かんで
その時 出会っていた文野君に
「紙切れかもしれないけれど
渋谷区でそういう証明書出したら嬉しい？」と
聞いたらですね
「めちゃ嬉しい」って喜ぶんですね
「なるほど」と　だったらこれを
少し企画にしていこうかなと思って
それを大体５年ぐらい前に思って
２年ぐらいかけて企画にして
３年前に区議会で提案しました
今までは人権の問題で 当事者ばかりが
言う問題だったんですけれど
僕のような アライ（Ally、盟友）
という立場― こないだ知ったんですけれど
そういう人間が提案する
それが大きな意義があったようです
さらに この渋谷という街は
僕は国際都市として
もっともっと発展していくべきだと思うし
国際都市として こういった問題を
クリアしていくことは
当然のこと 普通なことなんじゃないかと
あと渋谷は もっとカルチャーの面で
どんどんどんどん世界に発信していける
そういうポテンシャルのある場所
そう思った時にLGBTの人たちが
そのカルチャーに関わる発信力っていうのは
半端じゃなくデカイと思ったんです
だから渋谷がダイバーシティに
なっていく中でですね
彼らの問題を彼らが生き生きと
昼間から胸を張って生きられるような
そう言った街づくりが
必要じゃないかと思って
人権だけじゃなくて 渋谷が
ダイバーシティになっていくための
大きな条件の一つなんだって言うことを
当時提案して
その時の区長は僕の前の区長ですけど
今年80歳になる おじいちゃんって言ったら
怒られちゃうけど
そういう方だった
すごく頭のいい人なんで
頭では すごく理解してくれたんだけど
やはりなかなか心で理解できない部分も
実はあったんだと思うんです
でも僕が最初20歳の頃
そういうナンパされてですね
ちょっと「えっ」と思ったけど
段々とそういう人たちに会って
慣れていくうちに普通なんだって
彼もやはりそういうことを段々感じ出して
２年後にはこの問題を
検討する委員会ができて
それが去年の７月ですけど―
今年の１月にその委員会から
パートナーシップ証明 渋谷はちゃんと
出した方がいいよという答申が上がって
こないだの３月の議会で議論されて
可決されて 今に至っているんです
だから別に急な話ではなくてですね
僕にとっては割とロングストーリーというか
長い話があるんです
でもこれはまだ渋谷で第一歩だと思います
今僕が区長になって このことを引き継いで
10月末か遅くとも年内には
パートナーシップ証明書を
発行しようと思っています
こうやって渋谷が変われば
東京が変わるし
東京が変われば
日本が変わるかもしれないなと思っています
だけど そんな難しいことじゃなかったんだけど
なんで こんなに騒がれているんだろう？
というのが実は実感です
当たり前のこと、普通のこと
でも政治の世界で
僕らが等身大で感じることを
どんどんやっていければ
どんどん皆がもっと政治に
関心を持つようになると思うし
そうなれば もっともっと
変わりやすくなる
俺一人で世の中変えてやろうなんて
なめたこと全く思ってないです
だけど変わろうとするものの兆しを見つけて
そこの速度を上げていく
そんなことができたらなと思っているし
そんなことが実は僕に
合っているんじゃないかなと
今まで法律や条例を作ったり
それを審議していくことが
政治の仕事って思われていたけれど
本当に大切なのは 街の空気を
作っていくことだと思うんです
だから やっぱり条例とか法律とかだけじゃ
街の空気は変わらないと思います
障がい者についても
今度パラリンピックが来るんで
いい機会かなあと
さっきのLGBTの問題にも似てますけど
大切なのはマイノリティのことを
サポートするってこともそうですけど
マジョリティの僕らの意識を変えることが
大切なんだと思います
障がい者もパラリンピックを
皆見るとですね
すごいなって皆思う人
沢山いると思うんですね
ロンドンのパラリンピック
素敵だなと思いました
ポスターがすごい気に入ってます
脚のない人、腕のない人、車椅子の人が
かっこいい写真で飾られていて
そこのコピーが
"Meet the Superhumans"となっていて
今まで手を差し伸べる対象だった人が
初めて尊敬される対象に変わる瞬間が
あのポスターで僕は読み取れました
これが成熟した都市の
条件なんだなって思いました
青臭いって言われるかもしれないけど
ロンドン・パリ・ニューヨーク・渋谷区
そう言われるような
街づくりをしたいと思っています
面白いアイデアがあったら
どんどん区役所に言いに来てください
今まで区役所は 文句とか
言われる場所になっているんですけど
このTEDもそうだけどポジティブな提案を
どんどん受けつけたいんです
もちろんそこで
ネガティブな提案もいいんだけど
やっぱり区役所の人も
ポジティブなことを言われたらやりたくなるし
僕だって褒められたら伸びるタイプの人間です
是非皆と一緒にですね
面白い渋谷区、新しい渋谷区を
作れていけたらなあと思っています
本日はこのような機会をいただき
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）
Thank you very much!